wieder ein illegales autorennen wieder
ein schwerer unfall dadurch wieder
mitten in hamburg zwei junge männer
haben sich mamas auto dafür geschnappt
und diesmal diesmal gab es verletzte
mittwochnacht in hamburg ein bmw m 240 1
340 ps bolide der superklasse komplett
demoliert am steuer zwei junge männer
die sich den 60.000 euro teuren
schlitten schnell mal von mutti
ausgeliehen haben einmal richtig putzen
und mit mamas bmw ordentlich gas geben
im wahrsten sinne eine lebensgefährliche
schnapsidee denn die beiden hatten vor
ihrer spritztour ordentlich getankt den
alkoholtest hat der fahrer mehr als
bestanden 1,8 und 70 brummel und damit
der alkoholpegel stabil bleibt haben
sich die jungen männer vor ihrem
waghalsigen ausflug auch noch ein fabia
eingeladen das motto des fahrers bmw
oder ballermann in jedem fall
badelatschen mit
ordentlich karacho ging es dann durch
die hamburger innenstadt am ende eines
autotunnels verlor sohnemann die
kontrolle über das auto der wagen
knallte mehrfach gegen die tunnelwand
und überschlug sich totalschaden und die
beiden jungs waren nicht alleine worauf
stehen proleten richtig möpse gleich
zwei davon saßen auf der rückbank
während die beiden raser wie durch ein
wunder unversehrt geblieben sind trug
einer der möpse jedoch schwere
verletzungen davon er würde direkt am
unfallort von der feuerwehr versorgt
nachuntersuchungen umgehend in eine
tierklinik gebracht erste ermittlungen
der polizei haben ergeben dass der sucht
fahrer mit viel zu hoher geschwindigkeit
unterwegs gewesen ist laut der polizei
hamburg kann man von einem illegalen
autorennen ausgehen sowohl die mutter
als auch die trunken fahrer selbst
wollen sich nicht zu äußern
was von dieser gemeingefährlichen
raserei übrig bleibt sind ein auto mit
totalschaden
zwei betrunkene junge männer mit einem
führerschein weniger zwei traumatisierte
möpse und mehrere flaschen bier immerhin
noch ungeöffnet
[Musik]